and god speak all these words saying i
am the wrath thy god which have brought
me out of the land of egypt out of the house of
bondage thou shalt have no other gods before me
i shall not make unto thee any driven image or
any likeness of anything that is in heaven above
all that is in the earth beneath all
that is in the water under the earth
thou shalt not bow down thyself to them nor serve
them for i the lord thy god i am a jealous god
visiting the iniquity of the fathers upon the
children unto the third and fourth generation
of them that hate me ensuring mercy unto thousands
of them that love me and keep my commandments
thou shalt not take the name of the lord thy god
in vain for the lord will not hold him guiltless
that taketh his name in vain remember
the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou deliver and do all thy
work but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god in it thou shalt not do
any work thou not my son not my daughter
thy man's servant not my maid servant not a
cattle nor thy stranger that is within thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in there is
and rest in the seventh day wherefore the lord
blessed the sabbath day and hallowed honor thy
father and thy mother that thy days may be long
of under land which the lord thy god giveth thee
thou shalt not kill thou shalt not
commit adultery thou shalt not steal
thou shalt not bear false witness against thy
neighbor thou shalt not covet thy neighbors out
thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife
nor his manservant nor his maidservant
nor his ox nor his ass nor anything that is god
is good and all the time psalm 100 5 for the lord
is good his mercy is everlasting and
his truth endureth to all generations
as long as there's god there will be truth
the bible says his truth will endure to
all generations on the other side of that coin one
day error will come to an end truth will continue
forever but error will come to an end along with
those who persist in living their lives by error
it is not in the original design of god
to destroy people god is a god of life
the bible says sin has the power of death
because of sin god finds it necessary
to destroy but destruction is strange work
for god punishment is strange work for god
and too often we compel god to carry out these
strange acts by the way we live but it is not in
god's original plan at all that one person should
die in ezekiel 33 11 the bible says say unto them
as i lift said the lord i have no
pleasure in the death of the wicked
i am honored by god to be with you tonight i say
that realizing that the recording angel is writing
what i say i am honored by god to be with you
it is an honor to speak for god can you say amen
i would have been highly honored to speak for my
president but i have come tonight to speak for god
amen because of this i am compelled by the spirit
to declare thus in the lord and nothing else
servant of god writes the words of the bible and
the bible alone should be heard from the pulpit
and so i will give you thus saith the lord and
i will keep all my opinions useless as they are
to myself is there anyone with us
tonight you are not the seventh
raise your hand you are not a civilian just ah
would you kindly stand please i saw her all right
what's your name
what did she say
i was close to musu in a little town called yeli
thank you very much and they told me if you
look in that direction you're looking at
one day i want god to take me to luke thank
you very much for coming by this system i mean
the lord bless your life and the next time i come
back i want you to be a member of the church amen
god bless you take care of
you yes what's your name
nice to see you i'm fine chad where are you
from right around here thanks for coming jack
we're honored by your presence you could
have been somewhere else you chose to be
with us amen may not place a hand of mercy upon
your shoulders and never remove it say amen
how are you i'm fine you're wearing a blue shirt
blue in the bible is the color of obedience
i like that color i think this is blue it could
be wrong what's your name my name your name is
um is that around here okay all right thanks
for coming my dear brother god bless you may
the lord provide your needs and bless you
so much that you become a blessing to others
let me tell you a little secret don't tell anyone
i am standing in my favorite
country outside of the united states
i say don't tell anyone because my friends
all of that and they won't take it kindly
i don't know why i asked god from time to time
why do i love this country i first came in 2000
and like the talent of an eagle the country's
psychics claws into my eyes and i can't dislodge
the clothes and so i'm always delighted when god
sends me an invitation by god's grace and his will
i have spoken in uh cape town a few times a little
place outside of port elizabeth called otherwell
and gravestown rhodes university uh kimberly i
saw that big home mafiking but right outside the
magicking little rural area called marissa i think
i said that correctly i have spoken johannesburg
soweto very precise stunning hill where
else have i spoken uh port elizabeth uh
praetoria uh and so by god's
grace i have butterworth
i was there to assemble so i thank god i really
thank god and i will reward god tonight by just
giving you thus said the lord can you say
amen amen now this church is called kyle
whatever it is when christ comes we're all
going to the new jerusalem can you say amen
don't miss it don't listen for anything
on earth don't miss it for position
don't miss it because of money don't miss it
because of romance don't miss it because you
covered a career and damages you spiritually
do not miss a place in god's kingdom
all right let me get to the
message it is righteousness
right through what did i say righteousness
right through i don't see a clock anywhere
it's not the best place for it to be
turned right let me turn around once
7 30. can i let you up 8 15 is that excessive
how many of you have been out of work
something is right assist right
through uh do me three favorites
wherever possible if you brought two of these
unfortunately this is all you have then make
sure it does not ring are you with me let
me tell you a little secret about god that he
wants the whole world to know god is not casual
we feel he was casual and then we behaved casually
you see the romans had their gods
they were made in their image
am i talking to myself the roman gods
were made in the image of the people
and so they committed adultery they fought
each other they lied they overthrew one
another the greek gods did the same thing
because they were made in the image of man
we try to make god in our image and we make him
casual because of that we dress a certain way to
come to god we speak a certain way in god's church
we disregard god's command because he is casual
god is not when god came down on sunday night
moses said he exceedingly feared
and quit his knees were locking
this is most now if moses's niece could knock
and his chalk could chatter what about me god
and others intentions were upright he thought that
mark was about to fall but god can take care of
what is his right and the law was do not touch the
ark other with good intentions touch the ark you
finish the story god struck him dead that's not a
casual god before god came down on sinai in exodus
19 he told moses to tell the people take heed unto
thyself and of the people that he go not up into
the mount or touch the borders whosoever touches
the mount shall be surely put to death this is
holy because i've come down on it do not pass this
line if you touch it you're dead and that included
don't be afraid of god but reference god
reference god the way you'd reference your
president if he gave it to this church
you don't stand and salute or whatever you do
to show respect god deserves more than that
how many of you love god can i see your health
you love god god bless you like that he's happy
god loves to be told i love him he loves it
more than the ladies too he loves to be tall
i love you number two while i'm speaking pray for
me and say lord put your words in that man's mouth
that is based on jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then
the lord puts forth his hand and touched my mouth
but the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth what a tremendous
honor to have god put his word right in your
mouth because his words are spirit and life
mine are not and so i want god's words if you pray
that prayer god will answer you and what i say
will be a blessing so in praying for me you
protect your mind number three i want you to think
thinking is not as automatic as you
think a lot of people just don't think
they just act they react they don't respond
they react so you slap me i slap you right
back that's not a response that's a reaction
think if more people would think they
would not eat the things they did
they would not drink the things they drink
they would not date the people they dated
they would stop and think that it could be
somebody right now needs to decide father i
need to break off that relationship because i'm
still thinking right now this is no good since i
started seeing that man i go to church less often
i fight for my parents i don't study the bible
i've forgotten all the books about why i need
to stop and think yes relationship is toxic and
you're going to the gym to lose weight after
three months you've gained 30 pounds you need
to stop and think what's going on think isaiah 18
come now let us reason together said the lord you
and i serve a reasonable and a reasoning god here
is an example jeremiah 12 5 if thou has run with
a large part of christianity is
concepts guided by the spirit of god you
huh if you can't keep up with her
how can you keep up with a horse
let's pray holy father i stand before
you to god in need of grace i am dirt
and father weak all i can offer to you
is what you've given me which is the life all i
can offer to you now father is my power of speech
my mind all of me that you may use me
to god as a musician uses an instrument
i offer the resistance to you i
humble myself before today god
the carnal nature i possess loves attention it
loves glory and that's feeling god through your
spirit suppress it and let the spirit have his way
with me forgive me where i've offended you father
and grant me hatred for saying because the things
we hate we avoid bless my brothers and sisters
in this church their lord a very special blessing
on our three visitors father let their experience
with us tonight be such that they will come back
and be with us again bless this country of south
africa let the leaders always keep in mind when
they deliberate righteousness exalted a nation
and any other nationality in this congregation
father bless those countries we pray now father
as an act of mercy help me as i deliver
this message bless your people wherever
they worship there may be others in other
churches they are right now having services
bless their father and through the mysterious
agency of your spirit unite all our hearts as well
i pray for my heart dear god in jesus name that
god's people say amen and amen what's our subject
righteousness right ii peter chapter 3 let's read
from verse 10. ii peter 3 reading from verse 10
i read from the king james version of the
bible and if that's the version you have
i would be delighted if you would read with
me we don't read god's word enough and there
should be more reading of god's word in the
church and the righteous fellow white as well
have you found second peter chapter three verse
10 but the day of the lord will come as a thief in
the light in the woods the heavens shall pass away
with the great knowledge and the elements shall
melt with fervent heat the earth also and the
works that have everyone shall be one burned up
see then that all these things shall be locked
this all means what manner of persons ought to
be in all holy conversation and cognitive if you
know a flood is coming to destroy who will let you
will that change your behavior the flood is coming
i will say eight o'clock will that not change how
you behave will you not gather the essentials from
your house and go to higher ground if you know
there will be a shortage of fuel beginning on
monday will you not put fuel in your car tomorrow
sunday to be ready for that crisis seeing them
that all these things shall be dissolved there is
reasoning think what manner of a person's body to
be in all holy conversations being lifestyle and
godliness looking for and hasting unto the coming
of the day of god we're in the heavens being on
saturday this earth and the element shall now
refer for the key so peter's appealing to us
nevertheless we according to this promise
look for you come on and you finish the verse
women dwell in righteousness now number three
let's think let's go back look at the last
two lines of our standard the earth also
and the words that natherine finish it for me
shall be burned up this is a very opposite to
wherein dwelleth righteousness you understand what
i'm saying the works of this world are anything
but righteousness because god does not destroy
righteousness oh come on you want to say that
god cannot destroy
righteousness to destroy righteousness is
self-destruction because god is righteous
that's why when your life
is in the hands of christ
and you're covered by his
righteous life you cannot be lost
and so the earth also and the works that
are varied what are the words gambling
uh what's that word that people do
to steal money from the government
divorce adultery
abuse carjackings war ebola violence prisons
burglaries the works of this world shall be
burned up they'll come to an end but we're
told in verse 13 nevertheless we according
to his promise and he cannot lie look for you
and new earth wherein dwelleth righteousness
to prepare for that world you don't
prepare by living a sinful life
as i told the church last night in uh if you have
a physics exam next thursday what do you study
physics if we have an exam and righteousness
coming called the judgment are you with
do we practice sin in preparation for an
exam list of righteousness no we practice
righteousness in preparation for a judgment
based on righteousness and i will show that
nevertheless we according to his
promise look some of us for christmas
we're looking for a birthday that's coming next
month that we're anticipating to give you begin
from our husbands our friends some of us are
looking for that graduation date in september
but i was just nevertheless according
to his promise look this is expectation
you look
unto them that look for him shall
you hear the second time without sin
under salvation you must live a life
of expectancy there is something
coming united states when the new iphone is about
to be released people line up outside the stores
to be the first in to get there that
costs a thousand two hundred dollars
they expect and they look for
it and they thinking about it
nevertheless we according to his promise look
some young ladies looking forward to the wedding
some young married woman is
looking forward to her child
some proud fathers looking forward to the
day but he could bless talking with his son
somebody else is looking forward to the
day when you get an increase in your
money salary always ruled it hasn't changed and
so i said again second peter 3 13. nevertheless we
according to his promise look for new
heavens a new earth wearing dwelleth
if you're anticipating a righteous world you must
get ready for the judgment that qualifies you for
that world let's go to acts 17 the book of acts
written by luke by the real you wrote two books
and so what was the other one
he wrote look yes yes the gospel
luke 17 we'll read verse 31 our
subject righteousness right through
13 minutes what did you say the book
of acts chapter 17 thanks for asking
if i say something you're confused don't sit
quietly and look as though you understood
just raise your hand and say
what did you say say it again
what book did i say what chapter one verse 31.
the standard by which we are
judged which qualifies us for
that world which is righteous is righteousness
he has appointed a day in the which he
will judge the world in righteousness
by that man whom he hath who's that man jesus
christ and who's he that will work for that
man god the father has will carry on the judgment
through jesus christ now the world participating
in it dwells only righteousness the standard that
determines your fitness online for access to that
world is righteousness let's look at the judge who
sits in the judgment second timothy chapter four
you read for verse seven our subject righteousness
right through i guess that they say ten to eight
or their amounts what book did i say
one chapter ready for one verse seven
but your founders say amen amen some of you are
still working advocates used to be able to find
the books of the bible very quickly but their
faults came and screens came and there was a lot
of the need to search the bible you just read them
off the screen and we're losing that ability uh
it used to be the people of the book right
now the people of the phones okay second peter
chapter four seven and eight before i read it
let me pray again father in heaven i don't want
to go too long without seeking more power speak
to me god i really mean it suppress the flesh
and let the spirit have his way in jesus
name i pray amen i have fought in the fight
i have finished my course i have kept the faith
henceforth there is a letter from me what a crowd
of righteousness which the lord righteous church
shall give me at that day now what's our subject
righteousness is right through describe
the world we desire to enter righteous
world describe the standard of the judgment
righteousness now describe the judge righteous
i graduated from high school i have a vegetable's
degree in something a master's in something else a
doctoral degree in something else postdoctoral
degree from some intergalactic institution
i have this award this plaque this
medal from the president we have almost
if you were to apply for a job versus
accountant price waterhouse country and
they said you have training and accounting
you said yes they want proof what do they
it's not that they consider you a liar but i
want something that is a visual representation
of what you see you possess are you with me if you
tell your professor i know all the history but he
gives an exam show me the exam is the visual
evidence that you know what you said you know
now there's a visual representation of the
righteousness we see we have let's read
second timothy chapter four verse eight again
henceforth there is leader from iraq a crown
of jesus yes which the rights of the lord the
righteous judge shall give me and so we have a
world that is distinguished by righteousness
the standard is righteousness the judges
righteous and the crown is righteous you
see that crown you know what's inside
and there's no variation
now the question has to be asked
before we ask the question let's look at
the highest expression of righteousness
jeremiah 23 you read verses 5 and 6 our subject
righteousness right through what time is it
jeremiah we read verses 5 and 6.
read your family and say amen if you
have my version you may read with me
behold this comes in the lord that i will do
a great unto david of righteous branch and the
king shall do one reign and prosper and shall
execute church book and justice in the earth
in his days jewish shall be saved and israel
shall dwell safely and this is his name whereby
he shall be all tell me the lord our righteousness
jesus christ himself is the righteousness we need
making a personal righteous is an
intimate act christ has to be in you
righteousness requires an intimate
union between christ and a believer
and this is his name whereby you shall be
called the lord our righteousness now god
of first corinthians chapter 1 verse 30. let's
back up what we read in jeremiah 23 6 our subject
righteousness right through you
have first corinthians 1 verse 13.
are you still looking
all right let me read now what do you say
read with me all of him are we in christ jesus
who of god is leader to us what
wisdom come on and righteousness and
and rejection christ is our wisdom he is our
wife righteousness he is our lord he is our what
jesus said in john 14 6 you know verse very well
i am the way i am in the truth i am the life
he told martha at lazarus's grave i am the
resurrection not i have the resurrection
i am the resurrection i am the life
i am the truth i am the way i am
the wonder when moses said exodus 3 behold
when i come unto the children of israel
and shall say with them now the god of your
fathers have sent me unto you and this shall say
to me what is his name what shall i say to them
and not say tell them i am i am defense i am food
i am a cooling cloud of the day i am a warming
fire knight i am the water from that rock and
describe the world where we're going
righteous then describe a standard
a righteous standard describe the judge
a righteous shall describe the crown
a righteous crown and who personifies all
of that jesus christ our righteousness
now you must ask the question
what is righteousness
let's go to deuteronomy chapter 6
deuteronomy 6 you read one first verse 25.
romney 6 reading verse 25 iran is book number
five written by moses on most of it by moses
not chapter 34 because moses could not write
about his own death deuteronomy 6 verse 25
may my heavenly father continue to speak through
me for his glory and your blessing do you have it
yes now if you have my version read with
me let's read microscopically are you ready
and it shall be our righteousness here's
the eight if we observe to do what all
these commandments before the lord our god as he
had commanded us yes now i'll read it and use it
and it shall be our righteousness what is
the eight the bible the word tells us if we
observe to do give me one word for observe to
do obey god bless you in every possible way
obey what's the next expression
all these commandments
god is not a statistician see a statistician
looks at 9.6 what does he call it
10 there are experts in rounding
off god does not round off
9.6 for god is 9.6 god is a mathematician
a lot of christians we worship god's statistics
i keep my commandments why are you so
strict 90 is excellent in any institution
you see adam committed what we say
god through him
for how many mistakes
now you talk to me you reason with me
if god expelled a man for one
mistake what does god require of us
perfection not a rounded kind of obedience
and it shall be our righteousness
if we observe to do really within our all these
commandments come on before the lord our god as he
hath commanded us some christians
keep commandments not commanded by god
did you follow me
let me say it again the bible says who's
able to save and to destroy james 4 12
james was the half brother jesus there is one
longever the christian world has at least one
okay one will give yourself a
service and one who gives something
the bible says and it shall be our righteousness
if we observe to do all these commandments
before the lord our god as he has commanded us
so if the state tells you work on sabbath you
have to say with all respect you can't do it
if the state tells you stop singing
him you say okay you stop singing
there's no commandment saying thou shalt say hips
if the state says you must wear
white dresses wear white dresses
if the state says stop meeting
a church building media
all these commandments as he has what does
that verse tell us righteousness is right doing
everything you know god has shown you let me say
it again you missed it god will show him this much
and they shall be that much if he's faithful
to this monster as a righteous man if i am
faithful to my little bit that's a righteous
man so when he says all all that i have read
no some of us there are some things we
know we ought to do we don't do them
and we think we can make up for that
differently it could be there's someone listening
to me now you are violating god's commandments
knowingly willfully deliberately purposefully
intentionally and you call yourself a child of god
the only one who benefits from them
righteousness is not knowing what the bible
says righteousness is doing what the bible says
even if all you know is this let's get
an example of a righteous man let me pray
father as i go into this section of
the message coming close to the end
speak through me god please in jesus
name amen genesis 6 reading from verse 1.
genesis 6 reading from verse 1.
do you have that
genesis 6 reading from verse 1
if you found it amen and it came to pass when
men began to multiply on the feast of the earth
and daughters were born unto them that
the sons of god saw the daughters of men
that they were fair and they took the wives of
all which they chose the lord said my spirit
shall not always strive with man for that he
also is flesh yet his day shall be 120 years
there were giants in the earth in those days
and also after that when the sons of god
came in unto the daughters of men and their bear
children to them in the same beginning mighty men
richmond of old men of renown now read verse
5 with me and god saw no guesswork with god
are you with me and god saw that the wickedness
of man was great in the earth and that
every imagination of the thoughts of
his heart was only evil continually
there's something all they think about
is how can i corrupt the next woman
i need men in the church how can i
corrupt the next move that's all this
they say nothing but they dress a certain
way they say nothing but they walk where
you can sleep are you following me they
said nothing but they walk a certain way
you can't accuse him of anything but
god sees the heart are you following me
and god saw that the wickedness of man was great
in the earth and that every imagination of the
thoughts of his heart was only evil continually
and it repented the lord that he had been
man on the earth and he grieved him at
his heart god regretted having made man
every day you and i put on heads on the pedal
we shall say father i hope as you looked over
my life today you did not regret letting me live
and lord said i will destroy man who has created
from the face of the earth both man and beast and
the creeping thing in the house of the air
for it repent of me that i don't need them
that's verse 1-7 describing the wicked first it
says but noah found grace in the eyes of the lord
noah was a just man and perfect in his generations
and noah walked with god now let's think again
we can take the positive information about noah
and come to correct conclusions about the negative
information of those in verse 1-7 because
noah was a just righteous upright the bible
says you walk with god we know that the women
did not walk with god are you following me
noah was a just man we know that
those from verse one to seven were
not just those are perfect in his generations
we know those in verse one to seven were not
noah
the earth also was corrupt before god
and the earth was filled with violence
and god looked upon verse
12 and behold it was corrupt
for all flesh had corrupted his way let me
borrow from them no one can make you a sinner
so stop blaming your wife or your husband no one
can make you a sinner you have to choose to say
as the bible says in verse 12 of genesis 6 and god
looked upon the earth and behold it
was for all flesh had corrupted his way
god came down into the garden and said where's
thou adam said i heard my voice in the garden
and i was afraid because i was naked and
i hid myself eve didn't hide me i hate
sin is a personal choice but one of the things
sin did to the mind is to cause us to blame others
so my son isn't walking with god anymore
because the youth department was terrible are
you following me not because i failed in my home
the youth department was not good we blame others
all flesh had corrupted his way
verse 13 and god said unto noah
before the end of all flesh has come before
me for the earth is filled with violence
through them and behold i will destroy him
in the earth now god gives noah instructions
make the an ark of wood room shall
not make in the ark and shall pitch
it within and without with pitch and this
is the fashion which thou shalt make it off
the length of the arm shall be 300 cubits the
breath of it is of it 30 kilometers a window
shout out made to the ark and in a cubit shall
not finish it above at the door of the arm shaft
that was set in the size they're all with lower
second and third story shalt thou make all those
shall die but with thee will i establish my
covenant and thou shalt come into the earth
with thy sons of my wife and i sense wise with
you now he gives him more instructions and of
every living thing of all flesh versus mighty
two very small shall i bring it to the earth to
keep them alive with thee they shall be male and
see them are foul after they kind and have kept
up with the kind and of every creeping thing on
the earth after his kind two of every soul shall
come at least to keep them alive and take thou
unto thee of all food that is eaten and thou shalt
gather to the unto them and it shall be fulfilled
for the end of them number three verse 22 come on
king james version read with me thus did nobody
according to most that the lord commanded him
no one could not vary in one detail from all the
instructions the bible says thus did not according
to all the lord commanded me come on that's a
righteous man now read verse one of chapter seven
here comes more details of everything beast thou
shalt you to thee my severals the male and his
female and of peace that are not clean by two
the male and his female a fouls also in the air
by seven the male and the female to keep seed
light upon the face of all the earth for yet seven
days or forty days and i will call it to read up
at the earth walk forty days and forty nights and
every living one substance tonight i'm late will
i destroy some of the face of the earth three
the lord commanded him look at verse 22 of
chapter 6. do you see the word commanding
yes look at verse 5 of chapter 1
chapter 7 do you see the word command
whatever god said finish my words
nobody yes that's a righteous man
everything god said
when god gave instructions to moses for
building the ark of the taliban you can
read exodus chapter 25 to 40 to read all the
mind new details most could not alter one detail
when neighbor came from the masses to be healed
of leprosy he came to elijah at the request of the
recommendation of the little girl's faithful
building elijah did not even leave his room
elijah said to servant teleported
in jordan's seventh time
neymar went off the rails he did not even
come agree with me does he know who i
he's only asking you to dip seven
times and he pleaded with him
no the lord does not ask difficult things
god said the pattern very early he
said to adam all the trees on earth
are heroes except one did you know what
they said all the trees are atoms except
gold said i don't i made seventies you take six
you take all except one
all the wealth belongs to me you have
a hundred rounds give me ten you know
god doesn't get what he wants absolutely
live seven thirds they would have lost
him first he finally went when he
did six times he was still alive
that's one window one two three four
five six seven eight nine let's
call it ten you're level ten
how many do we have to break to
disrespect god so the bible says
if you keep the whole law and yet the third one
is
that's up to you with god
righteousness is doing whatever god says but it
must be done not from your liver or your spirit
it must be done from where object lessons page 97
paragraph three let me pray for it father coming
to the end continue to sustain it by your spirit
in jesus name i pray amen the mayor christ loved
the lessons page 97 paragraph three the man
who attempts to keep the commandments of god
from a sense of obligation merely because
he's required will never enter into the joy of
comes from the heart compliance
comes at the end of a gun
too many christians comply they don't obey
listen to the words of the prophet again the
man who attempts to keep the commandments
of god from a sense of obligation merely
because he's required to do so will never enter
into the joy of obedience he does not obey
when the requirements of god are accounted for
burden because they cut across human inclination
we may know that the life is not a christian
life how many of us we can't wait for the
sun to set so we can go watch manchester
united and arsenal are you following me
true obedience is the outworking of a principle
within it springs from the love of righteousness
the love of the lamb of god the essence of
all righteousness is loyalty to our redeemer
this will lead us to the right because it is
right because right doing is pleasing to god
we do what's right not because it is profitable
because in the eyes of the world it is not
profitable to close your business on saturday
that's when most people are out and about
with a lot of people the only barrier they
have is closing their business on samples
fix that they're jumping but obedience is
not conditioned upon convenience or profit
it simply is based on i love
him and whatever he says
that's the world you're
going to do whatever god said
my highest joy is not seeing you know somebody
with a race or winning the lottery my highest
joy is doing whatever god said and so jesus
said he that have sent me is with me the
father hath not left me alone for i do always
those things that please him what's our subject
righteousness right through describe
the world we desire to enter righteous
describe the judgment righteous describe the
judge writers describe the crown righteous
i could say one moment i have to disclose
make a commitment right now say father
help me to obey you as an act of love amen the
bible says for god so loved the world that he
gave his only begotten son christ on that cross
he stayed on that cross that was the father's will
he complied with father's will yes he
loved us too but when he prayed lord if
the father if thou be willing remove
this cup from me nevertheless not my
that's a righteous man christ lived that
life in your flesh and mind he says to us
you attach yourself to me and
the power that sustained me will
jesus came to show by trusting in him
you like to live a victorious life
and overcome his life a righteous life how many of
you want that life can i see you right
now do you mean that stand up with me
as far as i suppose father in heaven i'll
can a sinner such as i preach a perfect
sermon absolutely impossible where i felt short
forgive me thank god but let your spirit father
impress upon the hearts of those who
heard the truth that i tried to speak
all of my glory god the fields and for
the salvation of souls their father
the reason the world is in its condition
is because one man disobeyed you
the bible says we're forced to put an end to this
wonderful disobedience that they may experience
a life of righteousness which is obedience from
the heart that's why your law is written on the
heart not on the liver god help us to love
doing what's right just because it is right
give us a love for your law as your servant says
the law of god should be obeyed even though there
was no authority to enforce it and no reward
for its obedience because it is a good law
oh father give us a hatred for sin
and a love for righteousness i pray
and save us when you come god in jesus
name let god's people say amen amen
you